salut j'espère que vous avez bien c'est
dimanche matin je me suis on va faire un
truc bien fun en ce dimanche matin on va
parler maths c'est un suicide youtube
est ce que j'en ai bien conscience
avant de vous donner cette astuce cool
je vous donne la solution de l'énigme
d'hier la première solution de l'énigme
c'était 13 vous abouti sied à 13 au
final donc c'était la première partie de
l'énigme globale pour la deuxième il y
avait les deux rébus pour faire la
charade mon premier c'était l'oiseau il
coupe c'est donc un ni mon deuxième
c'était une équation à un 4/4 / 4 4 en
chiffres romains donc un quart et mon
tout précédé mon premier et mon second
dans une célèbre phrase mnémotechnique
que j'ai beaucoup entendu dans ma
jeunesse mais où est donc ornicar et
donc qu'est ce qui précède ni écartée or
donc la deuxième partie de l'énigme
global était or donc 13 or trésor
n'était pas très compliqué mais il
fallait prendre le temps de tout faire
et donc aujourd'hui une astuce de
mathématiques pour diviser un petit peu
plus facilement de tête génériques
d'années je vous ai donné régulièrement
des astuces pour le calcul mental ou
pour les matches j'ai même fait une
playlist pour ça qu'ils s'appellent truc
de maths
il n'y a pas beaucoup de choses sur la
division parce qu'il n'ya pas beaucoup
d'astuces en fait sur la division j'ai
hésité un moment donné à réapprendre à
faire une division à la main pour faire
une division sans calculatrice et puis
je me suis demandé si ça peut-être ça
allez vous saouler si vraiment vous
voulez une vidéo là-dessus mettez le
dans les commentaires et je verrai
suivant le nombre de personnes qu'il
réclame si je le fais ou pas mais je
suis pas persuadé que ce soit pertinent
mais aujourd'hui je me suis dit il ya
quelque chose dont je me sers
spontanément qui peut les intéresser
c'est pas tant pour la résoudre que pour
mieux la comprendre première astuce vous
regardez le nombre que vous avez à
diviser pour regarder la fin
ce nombre son dernier chiffre celui des
unités 6 termine par deux quatre six ou
huit
ça veut dire qu'il est divisible par
deux c'est une information que vous
savez il est père il est divisé par 2 6
termine par 5 c'est à dire qu'il est
divisible par 500 recule et s'ils se
termine par zéro c'est à dire qu'il est
lisible par 0 102e astuces que j'utilise
vous pouvez faire rapidement la somme
des chiffres qui composent le nombre si
ces 197 fait un + 9 puis 7 ça fait
dix-sept par exemple vous l'aurait dit
viser au maximum par exemple on 17 après
j'aurais fait un plus cette égalité
jusqu'à temps qu'il vous reste plus
qu'un seul chiffre
ça se fait très rapidement de tête et si
ce résultat de réduction est un multiple
de 3 ça veut dire que vous pouvez
diviser par 3 par exemple 168 ça fait 1
+67 +8 15-15 ça fait 1 + 5 6 6 un
multiple de 3
donc c / troisième point et là on va
passer très vite dessus c'est exactement
la même chose que le précédent mais pour
9,6 votre réduction finale est un
multiple de mer c'est-à-dire que le
nombre est divisible par neuf si on
prend 225 ça fait de plus de 4 +59 donc
225 s'est divisé par neuf et en fait ça
fait vingt-cinq fois de quatrième petit
ips six et dix visites par deux comme on
a vu dans le premier type
et si en plus la somme réduite est un
multiple de 3 comme on a vu dans le
deuxième type ce alors vous savez que le
nombre est divisible simplement par si
ça vous permet encore une fois de savoir
où aller et j'ai une dernière astuce que
j'utilise pour voir rapidement sinon les
divisible par quatre alors vous allez me
dire 4c 2 / 2 c'est pas faux en soi mais
pour être sûr d'avoir un intérêt à faire
que la double division et que ça tombe
juste il suffit de regarder
les deux derniers chiffres d'un grand
nombre c'est à dire le chiffre des
unités le chip des dizaines et si ces
deux derniers chiffres sont divisées par
quatre ça veut dire que le grand nombre
peu importe sa taille est divisible par
400 vérifier au préalable si je vous dis
849 1616 comme cez est divisé par 4 je
sais déjà que ce que je vais vous dire
est divisible par quatre voici quelques
astuces de division celle que j'utilise
personnellement qui peuvent vous
permettre d'avoir au moins un regard si
ce n'est pas de faire la division
mentalement facilement ça vous permet
déjà de savoir comment situez qu'est ce
qui va permettre de diviser j'espère que
ça vous a plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas à monter un pouce en l'air ou que je
sais c'est trash des matelas dimanche qu
est ce que tu veux je te dise demain on
rattaque une grosse semaine avec du
mentalisme du non verbal des
explications des invités encore plein de
trucs cool
en tout la gauche trouve cool alors
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
dallas
[Musique]